this morning on the dish Americans are
having a love affair with Portugal and
not just for vacations it has become one
of the Prime destinations for American
remote workers and right now about 45
percent of foreign home buyers in
Portugal are American among the
attractions amazing food including the
kitchens of award-winning Chef Jose
avilesch like his double Michelin
starred belcanto named one of the
world's 50 best restaurants and a venue
where we met up right by the sea
from the Iberian Peninsula panoramic
views of the Atlantic are breathtaking
and never lost on a Native Sun with a
global vision I love this wind and this
Aroma sea Chef josea Village grew up in
where he now claims a new window to this
world welcome
is his latest passion and here we have
one of the dining rooms covet delayed
construction but it's set to open in
November this was an old restaurant but
that closed like
35 years ago oh I still can come came
here with my father when I was a kid it
was called and I remember then this was
close and become completely destroyed on
one day the owner came to me and asked
me if I wanted to open a restaurant here
that ask based on his 20 years in the
industry one that began with private
lessons from the mother of Portuguese
Cuisine Maria de Lourdes Modesto he then
heightened his skills at El bouye with
Chef Iran Andrea in 2009 he earned his
first Michelin star at restaurant
Tavarez
[Music]
before stepping out on his own he caught
the eye of Anthony Bourdain in No
Reservations great meal including your
words
it's really nice in 2012 he opened
belcanto which earned its first Michelin
star the same year and over the next
decade he built an Empire of 20
restaurants from Lisbon to Dubai I
remember that the first menus most of
the Portuguese thought that I was
destroying the traditional Portuguese
Cuisine dishes like grilled sardines and
octopus flame grilled chorizo Cod
fritters and custard Tarts most chefs
hate the word Fusion but there is
combination of of influences here
inclusion rhymes with confusion so it's
not but it hasn't influences and I think
that even what we call now the
Portuguese traditional cuisine
300 years ago we didn't exist 400 like
it is today so a traditional evolution
is part of the tradition how would you
describe
the Portuguese way so I think one of the
most special things that we have the
word
for us
is to share to share is to care we are
trying to take care of the people who
see that at our tables that sentiment
was Amplified by Frank bruni's 2012
review in the New York Times and he said
I'm I'm tasting I'm seeing the future of
Portuguese Cuisine the best meal of the
year
and in three days the restaurant was
full booked
reservations are now booked a year out
what are we eating here there are some
dishes from our our la carte menu it's a
good thing we didn't need one this is a
Scarlet shrimp the red shrimp from
Algarve it's very typical from here it's
kind of sweet it has this amazing Umami
taste with a salad with asparagus and an
apple and the sauce is a curry the
Portuguese took the curry from India to
Thailand it's cooked rice with vegetable
charcoal and then we dried we fry we mix
yet he still finds a way to keep things
informal may I use my hand for this like
how he claims to have toned down his
artistic Whimsy I had a lot of dishes
that the names were landscape of this or
the colors of the sky or the poem the
dirt and our thoughts
maybe I'm being ridiculous I I need to
to make food again he now says he
creates dishes that pop like his smoked
avocado scaled sea bass or suckling
pigbelly with peppercorn sauce so we
have here symbolizing the egg sweets and
the monks and his finish a sweet egg
cream with a story all its own when the
monks needed the whites to to prepare
the clarified wine the nuns would do the
desserts with almond sugar and and egg
yolks his take on that history that we
add a little bit of lemon in on this
survey
of course this is a shell made of sugar
it's everything is edible
with that one
and expecting that go for it go for it
go for it a little bit of salt a little
bit of lemon juice it's that fun and
flavor that avilush says defines his
kitchen watch a little bit too salty a
little bit
I'm sorry so as I told you before I
don't yell oh the pressure of a live
audience
[Music]
you're fired
and while he lost a quarter of his
restaurants in the pandemic most of his
staff remains I'm as good as my team
they truly believe in what I believe
that we can do it better and then that
we can show the Portuguese Cuisine to
the Portuguese people but to the world
so chef abilish says he'll keep smelling
the roses and living in his passion
sometimes that you lose the pleasure of
what you're doing
because your focused on the wrong things
that it's the guides the lists and
sometimes that is only a balloon full of
air it's so important for you to keep
smiling to keep have pleasure of what
you're doing to keep working with your
team to have time for your family so you
need to take care of you
and he loves opening restaurants he
opened to this year Mari in November
another coming up next year guess where
that one will be where New York City
Beverly Hills California my hometown he
told me to keep it a secret but you're
not I'm just told everybody no he he's
he was kidding with me but he also sent
over his favorite signature drink it's
called the Primo basil okay take a sip
I'm so sorry we don't have custard Tarts
or any of that egg cream oh my gosh it
was amazing that's okay this is
delicious he specifically asked you to
keep it a secret no no he said it was a
what do we call it in journalism it's a
school good okay